we've brought up the Sri Lanka stuff and
also the Holland stuff like what
happened exactly to bring this famine on
is there is it would you consider a
famine at this point in Holland yeah uh
no no not in Holland there's a I mean
there's there's massive shortages in
grocery stores
um so that's I but that's not the
definition of a famine
um what's going on in the Netherlands
right now is the
prime minister and the court system
there are pushing this policy of
reducing nitrogen emissions by 2030. so
by 2030 the nitrogen emissions have to
be down by 30 40 percent and to do that
that means farmers are going to have to
Cull their herds because there's a lot
of nitrogen emission throughout the
whole process of raising cattle pork and
and all this so by calling the by
culling the herds they lose their profit
margins Farm Farms aren't the most
profitable Ventures you can go into most
people are in it because their families
were in it for a long time so they they
do this job and they say okay call 30 of
the herd they no longer can afford to
keep that land and for some reason keep
in mind the Dutch government has said
this is only going to be in effect in
environmentally sensitive areas which
which just happens to be around big
cities and coastlines high value real
estate which has caused people to say
well why are you targeting us why what
do you want the land is that what you
really want and it's become clear that
that's what the Dutch government wants
they want to evict these Farmers they
don't care about the food they want the
land and these are farms that have been
in families since the 13th century like
this is Europe we're talking about right
it's not not even America where the farm
that we're on right now or the Farmland
that we're on has been uh you know
farmed by Americans for 200 300 years
back there it's been 900 to you know 10
centuries so it's pretty tragic what's
happening there and it's even more
tragic that the mainstream media isn't
giving them a fair shot at saying their
peace they're immediately taking the
government's side and saying
you know they're extremists just like
the people that went to Ottawa they're
you know they're racists they're they
have no idea what they're talking about
but in reality they do know what they're
talking about and if you're not trusting
the farmers with our food supply I don't
know I don't think you should be
trusting journalism so this is a kingdom
it's the kingdom of the Netherlands yes
so King is is orchestrating this ah no
uh it's it's a it's
it's run by a parliament by a government
by a parliament so okay
we've got fuel shortages they don't know
if they'll be able to to have enough
fuel to harvest what they did grow let
alone you know if they could grow
anything at all because of the
fertilizer shortage they're telling us
that the surrounding countries outside
of Europe are going to be in serious
crisis because there's a lack of food
because they won't get imports from
Russia and Ukraine and when so Lebanon
may start turning into Sri Lanka and
then they tell the Dutch Farmers stop
farming
the food's already stopped production
why do they need to stop cut down the
nitrogen you know these countries are
eating themselves alive it's
self-immolation it is self-immolation
and it's just like Joe Biden cancels
Keystone XL and then and then gas prices
go through the roof it's like why'd you
do that you knew what was going to
happen I mean you didn't know maybe you
didn't know Russia was going to go to
war in the Ukraine but you know what
would happen with with uh Keystone XL
and now uh leaders around the world from
Sri Lanka to the Netherlands and Canada
Justin Trudeau is doing the exact same
thing putting limits on fertilizer use
in our country by by 30 he wants to
reduce fertilizer use and what does that
mean well half the planet is fed by
fertilizer in one way or another 50 of
the planets mouths ingest food because
of fertilizer which is frankly a gift
from God
um from Russia we yeah well from Russia
from from lots of places and and now
they're saying well Justin Trudeau is
saying specifically let's reduce that by
30 to help the environment well that's
reducing food output by a substantial
margin you don't just there's no
technology that replaces fertilizer you
don't just plant crops more straight or
give it more water without the
fertilizer it doesn't grow and you don't
feed people and then the question is
who's not eating who's not well I'm
eating I bought emergency food I don't
even worry about it and the funny thing
is is that like Suddenly It's nitrogen
that's what I would like yeah like where
did we decide nitrogen was this thing
that had to be regulated because we
always heard about methane but methane
is when it comes to the fossil fuel
industry so it's like well we can't kind
of oil and gas because that's methane
but when it comes to farming it's
nitrogen it's like oh how come it's not
methane because they don't have any oil
in in Holland but they do have Farms so
nitrogen is what we have to control and
you're like wow that's odd where was the
the decision that nitrogen is suddenly
this just like CO2 carbon remember Joe
Biden said it at the the Scotland
climate Summit that he was going to work
with the leaders around the world to rid
the atmosphere of carbon that would
destroy them exactly and all the plants
of the world were like please no like
everything alive but we've decided
carbon is bad and you want to say where
does this come from like what is the
driving impetus of this oh it's not
about nitrogen or methane or carbon it's
about land it's about power it's about
oh now it makes a lot more sense soon
they're going to be regulating oxygen
exactly that's the next one yeah it's
just that this is just an enormous
paragram it's a land grab and Europe is
going to have land grabs because Europe
is small no offense to our European
friends we love you but Europe is kind
Continental Europe is smaller than
America obviously than a lot much
smaller than Canada there isn't a lot of
land there to begin with
um so the land is going to be their
biggest problem but you guys power did
you guys see the viral video of the man
in his bin full of water in the UK no
it's hilarious video well I've seen
water because it's the hottest day in
history in the UK so he took his garbage
bin and he filled with water and he was
sitting in it
some guy pulls up my car and he's like
you're in the bin and he's like yeah and
he's like why and he's like I'm enjoying
the day and he's like but you're in the
bin and then the guy like well I'm
pretty sure it's fake but it's hilarious
anyway but it's like the the UK doesn't
have air conditioning I don't know if
you guys know this Europe doesn't yeah
it was crazy I went to the I went to the
UK for a speaking event they put me in a
hotel on the top floor it was like third
or fourth floor and it was like 90 some
odd degrees and then I was like guys
like I have to I have to go to a
speaking event
and I'm drenched in sweat because it's
so hot up here what am I supposed to do
and so they're like we'll try and figure
out a box fan for you I'm like that's
not gonna do anything but it's like
people are crazy but at least they're
green by stuffing everyone who's super
sweaty into public transit so they stand
shoulder to shoulder with people who
smell like socks I have an article from
seven years ago you're up to America
Your Love of air conditioning is stupid
I really have to say I wonder if they
still think that now yeah which
journalist wrote that listening no
they're going to say that our use of air
conditioning created more carbon
emissions which made the planet hotter I
agree yeah for sure
plant more trees man yeah you know trees
they eat carbon you just have to ignore
all of these fake metrics because it's a
it's a much more a nefarious agenda that
has nothing to do with the environment
or the planet you know I I think climate
change is an issue I think pollution is
an issue whether whether you believe in
climate change or not I think human
pollution is awful but it's really just
the cities and so you know we've talked
about this with people like Michael
malice and our where we come to
agreement is cities are too dense and
the cities produce a ton of waste like
if you had one guy let's say 100 people
and they're spread out over a mile each
person and they all take a dump
right all at once right when you drive
100 miles you might notice every mile
there's some poop on the ground or you
might just be like oh I didn't even
realize imagine if it was 100 people all
got together in the same city block
formed the circle and took a big dump
yeah you would definitely notice that
and the density of the human waste would
cause ecological problems this is what's
happening with these big cities their
gluttonous immature whiny resource Hogs
it's extremely resource intensive to get
food into New York City the roads are
congested there's brake dust and Smog
and pollution but you got to get that
food in there so now people are spending
five grand per month on average to get
an apartment the cost of living is
through the roof and then you move out
of the city and it's like really easy to
get to the grocery store way less
wasteful
there's a thing about people who live in
the countryside right more likely to
have their own source of food even if
it's a little bit people out here they
got chickens you know I I'll see houses
they'll have like two or three chickens
and I'm like they're getting some of
their food on their own the chickens
will go and eat bugs or grass and then
they'll get eggs from it that's a little
bit of making their own food they're
more likely to be uh to have solar power
it's harder to get solar if you're in an
apartment in New York city so you have
the houses out in the middle of nowhere
and people have more renewable energy
sources
I just look at the people who are living
out here and it's like well water yes
so they're not creating this big sewage
wastes the the septic system's handling
the waste and then putting the the leech
water out but yeah which are the people
who are pushing the climate agenda
though the people who want to fly around
in private jets the people who most of
them live in the city yep right they're
the ones like you said they are huge
energy sucks and they tell you you live
on the 87th floor of a building and you
don't think that requires tremendous
fossil fuels did you see who was it
Kylie or whoever she flew oh yeah
private jet she flew on a private jet
for 12 minutes and it was funny because
they said that she drove a half an hour
in the wrong direction to to get to the
airport for a trip that would have taken
20 mile 26 minutes to drive oh my God so
like it took her longer to drive to the
airport to get on the plane to fight to
fly like 20 miles or whatever
that's a very short two airports very
close to each other yep oh yeah it
wasn't Elon Musk who jumped from like
San Francisco to like San Jose over the
bay it was like a 10 minute flight
it's hey it's an hour two hour drive
with traffic that flight was five
minutes that's great and if you're Elon
you're like hey time is money baby let's
roll yeah that's it's yeah and I don't
begrudge them
that privilege I don't begrudge them I
don't believe fossil fuels are bad so
I'm never gonna say well we all have to
do our part to conserve I just don't I
don't buy that argument what I do are
begrudge are people who do that who want
to deny the rest of us that opportunity
like the John carries of the world who
right now is in some German Resort and
the Alps planning the climate conference
and he flew there on his private jet and
he's like but we have to get rid of our
fossil fuels it's like well you you're
never going to not eat steak here right
you're the same with you I'm sure Klaus
is at that meeting right and and I would
love to know what the the caviar
selection that was there yeah somebody
said Tim didn't grow that Vita cocoa
I came out of a chicken's butt yeah it
did actually Hawaiian chicken we
actually have a big coconut palm tree
and peaches and mangoes and it's all
it's hot enough here I didn't say all of
our food was was grown by us yeah it was
great having the garden your water is oh
yeah filtered pure well water yeah it's
amazing
that's good oh yeah yeah but it's like
super purified and then minerals added
back into it great yeah and then for a
freedom stand with the new studio it's
basically Off the Grid are you gonna
pump fluoride into the water systems oh
we do yeah we do double the fluoride
yeah
the new space we have yeah the new space
has got its own Pond good that we're
going to clean up it's got well water
obviously there's a pond right there
we've got solar power and backup
batteries so we're going to try and be
as self-sufficient as possible
uh it's not about like saving the planet
it's about just not getting getting
disrupted when we're doing work yeah but
you know hey I can then be smug and make
fun of all the city or Urban the city
Urban liberal types and be like wag my
finger at them based on their own
standards awesome no everyone should be
as self-sufficient as possible I'd love
to have a small nuclear reactor in my
backyardigration it would be fantastic
and and we thought about it because
again when Back to the Future came out
at the end he's got his little Mr Fusion
right in the back of the car we we
thought that's what the future was going
to be a little tiny nuclear reactor in
the back of your car we weren't afraid
of it in 1984 whenever that came up but
we're afraid of it now thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast IRL
come hang out live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm Eastern Time Super Chat will
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there then thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time